chuckle have you ever had a person you
couldn't get through to something that
you couldn't manipulate then what what
do you do when you can't get through
well yeah of course I've had people that
I could not get through to it and
generally speaking these people are like
level 12 arrogance that's what they are
giant ego that's what causes this there
was quite a few seal leaders that I
dealt with
I shouldn't say quite a few there were
several seal leaders that I dealt with
that were like that and of several
business leaders that I've dealt with
that I were like that in podcast number
five I read that counseling letter hmm
corrective measures to a guy that was
really arrogant and despite that letter
he did not change and he got fired so
what do you do when you got someone that
you can't get through to you you fire
them that's if they're if and here's
what you got to do is what what makes
that tricky is that some people and this
may this this will make people freak out
there are some people that they're such
good performers that even though they're
slightly negative on maybe their team
participation but they're so good that
that it offsets their negativity right
and that happens it happens you know
what happens with sales people sales
people are are in order to be in a sales
position you got to be confident you got
to be aggressive you got to be somewhat
arrogant right you got to believe in
yourself and so some salespeople take
that to the extreme where they're just
like I don't need to listen to what
you're telling me the new procedures are
yeah screw that I'm the one that's doing
the big dollars over here how about you
follow my procedures boys right so so
that happens well then what you got to
do is you got to look does is this guy
producing so well now that can create
problems within the team mmm and you
have to balance those things it is this
guy is the negative is creating offset
by the awesome product if ateva tees do
it and furthermore if the guy is that
good hey maybe we should be modeling
some things after them I have no problem
with that if you're the best performer
cool I want to imitate you I want to get
my people to him at 8:00 you
so that happens at the other place where
you might see it a similar situation is
a leader that does really good with
their relationships down the chain of
command for instance but it really has
bad relations up the chain of command so
again you got to ask yourself okay if I
fire this leader how many of these
people that he has great relationships
are now gonna leave and what kind of
detriment is that to the team that can
also happen with someone that doesn't
that treats their people like crap but
up the chain of command everyone thinks
is great and and he's getting the
mission done by the way mmm right he's a
slave driver and he's creating total
animosity between him and his team but
he's accomplishing the mission so now
how would he do there's a risk everyone
could quit there's risk you could fire
them and now you don't accomplish the
mission anymore this is why leadership
is hard and this is why you have to
balance everything mm-hmm you have to
balance those things but talked about it
a bunch of times if you get someone you
coach them you mentor them you do
everything you can you flank them you do
jujitsu mental jujitsu on them you try
and get them squared away and eventually
if you can't you weigh against you know
how it's gonna affect the situation and
then in many cases you got to let them
go
and we fired you know we fired five saw
plenty of seals get fired from
leadership positions and and same thing
with you know obviously we work with
consulting businesses we see all kinds
of people getting fired because they're
either not capable of doing their job
they're too arrogant and they don't
recognize that things are going sideways
and they're just thinking that they're
doing everything perfect no that's not
gonna work out well for you hmm
you know what did I think is Lafe
someone asked him you know when do you
know when's that line where it's like
when it's time to fire someone yeah and
he was like in a nutshell there's a lot
to it but in a nutshell which that was
dope
he said it's you know you're at that
point where you fire someone when when
you don't feel bad about it right right
so it's like yeah you you every tried
everything and and there's also people
boots there's some validity to this that
say the first time you think you should
fire someone you should fire that's the
other end of the spectrum right and what
that means is when you're looking at
someone and you're going man okay I can
save them I can help that's the kind of
advice you give to someone that's that's
a that's got a maternal instinct right
that you meet someone hey I know this
guy's just a good guy and everyone my
team is great and everyone's gonna do
great job you can't tell that person
what life and I normally tell people
which is when you feel good about it you
should fire him because that person will
never feel good about firing anybody
just insane because he decided duska I
know he's gonna make it no he's gonna
come around you know I and then they
then they start playing the the extreme
ownership game which is you know if I
would have given EKKO a better direction
he would have been able to do this it's
my fault yeah I've given EKKO 17
iterations of this and he still didn't
complete it correctly he's fired that's
the way it works right there's yeah the
balance so that spectrum of of you know
being within the confines of being
justified firing somebody a certain type
of person you gotta say when you don't
feel bad about it right right
I mean that's like a fire heavy type
dude right but there's also someone the
reason you shouldn't feel bad about it
is because I've done everything I can do
to help you yeah which takes work it
takes effort it takes tact it takes hard
conversations because it's hard for me
to go and say echo you know I've been
I've been looking at your videos lately
and they're they're not really what
we're looking for right I don't want to
say that to you and you know it's
uncomfortable and we're kind of like you
know we we want to get along so instead
I'm like yeah echo that that video is
good man yeah it's good but I'm not
telling you the truth and then over time
our videos are looking good enough and
eventually I say you know what
you know we're no one's buying our
videos anymore
or and we haven't gotten in new
contracts so guess what I'm gonna have
to let you go you're like what about you
said all the videos I made were good now
you're firing me maybe you need to
become a better salesperson yeah
whereas if I had the hard conversation
early and said hey echo you know I know
you're creative and I appreciate that
but we also need to get the message
across for our clients I'm obviously
fabricating a business where we're
making videos of applying for clients
yeah
which I know we don't really do a lot of
anymore occasionally you do but yeah you
got oh you got to have the hard
conversations earlier if I'm the type of
person that doesn't like to have the
hard conversations
once again I never feel good about it
cuz I never I never gave you any advice
so it always feels bad for me to fire
someone yeah but if you're following
good leadership tactics then absolutely
true when you get to a point where you
gotta fire somebody you won't feel bad
about it because you know you've done
everything you can
you know you've coach them mentor them
and you know that if you keep them on
board you are negatively impacting your
team which is bad yeah and then go down
to the other side of the spectrum still
within the confines of being justified
in firing somebody by the way but on the
other side of the spectrum you get how
you say that what do you call the
maternal instinct I'm a direct the
person who can like they're they're just
super hard on themselves maybe or
they're you know like even if you did do
everything you can you still like I
coulda done more you know so it's my
fault that is I feel like I let them
down as a leader yeah give them 17
counseling chits yeah you know they
don't belong here you can't do their job
stop yeah I mean well they're going home
laughing at you or whatever
yeah yeah you get that kind of
personality so it's kind of like how you
say you gotta balance it you got to be
like okay you gotta recognize okay what
kind of person am i you know or what
kind of person is this other person kind
of thing and if they're those maternal
instinct jool for lack of a better with
one person then what was it the first
time you feel like you should fire them
you should fire you you hang out on that
side of the spectrum you gotta yeah